- Pour avoir refusé de coopérer
dans l'enquête parlementaire
sur l'sasaut du Capitole
du 6 janvier 2021, Steve Bannon
est donc condamné à quatre mois
deririson et 6500 dollars
d'amende. Mais, il n'ira pas
tout de suite en prison. L Le te
d'appel lancée par son avocat,
il pourra restera en liberté,
a décidé le juge.
Un juge qui n'a donc pas retenu
les arguments de l'ancien proche
conseiller de Donald Trump qui
disait ne pas pouvoir témoigner
devant le Congrès puisque ses
discussions avec l'ex-président
étaient frappés de la
confidentialité du privilège
présidentiel.
Or, Donald Trump n'a pas ioqoqué
ce droit et Steve Bannon,
qui était un citoyen privé,
le 6 janvier, ne peut donc pas
s'en prévaloir. Même chassé de
la Maison Blanche, Bnonon était
resté proche du président
républicain et avait encore
échangé avec lui le 5 janvier
2021, à la veille de l'attaque
contre le Congrès.
Après leur conversation,
il avait même prédit
un déferlement infernal
le lendemain, à Washington.
Fidèle à sa réputation
d'agitateur en chef, il n'a pas
pu s'empêcher de déclarer ceci,
après le prononcé en ce jour
de sa peine de prison.
" Le 8 novembre, dit-il, sera
le jour du jemement du régime
illégitime de Biden et l'on sait
comment cela va finir".
Questionné sur la peine
de l'ex-conseiller de son rival,
Joe Bin n avait cette courte
réponse:
"Je ne commente jamais ce qui
concerne Steve Bannon".
Quelques heures plus tard,
Donald Trump a reçu son
assignation à comparaître
devant le comité de la Chambre
qui enquête sur l'assaut
du Capitole. L'ex président est
vu comme l'incitateur en chef
des événements qui ont conduit à
lala mort de plusieurs personne,
et de saccages du Congrès.
Tout cela pour tenter d'empêcher
la certification des résultats
officiels qui ont consacré
la victoire du président
démocrate. Donald Trump
jusqu'au 14 novembre pour
répondre à l'assignation
à comparaître. Et jusqu'ici,
il n'a pas vraiment donné
de signal dans un sens
comme dans l'autre.
Ici Frédéric Arnould,
Radio-Canada, Washington.